More financial trouble for Russia today.
The credit rating agency, S&P Global, says...
...Russia effectively defaulted on its foreign debt...
...after offering to make payments in rubles instead of dollars.
Matt Egan joins me now.
So Matt, this is a consequence, it seems, of some of the sanctions on Russia,...
...but what are the practical implications for Moscow?
Yeah Dana, this really is all about sanctions.
Russia owed payments on interest, and they owed it in dollars.
But they tried to pay in rubles, not because they don't have dollars.
They do.
They just can't access those dollars because of sanctions from the West.
And so that's why S&P has downgraded Russia...
...into what they're calling "selective default,"...
...which is when a country defaults on specific obligations but not its entire debt.
Now, technically, Russia has 30 days here to make these payments,...
...but S&P does not think that Russia will do so, at least not in dollars.
So, what does this all mean for the economy?
Well, a default would raise borrowing cost for Russia.
Investors are not gonna want to do business with Russia.
And this is also adding to the economic pain there.
They're experiencing very high inflation, shrinking standard of living,...
...and this exodus of Western companies.
And World Bank says that Russia is already in default.
The World Bank expects Russia's GDP to decline by 11 percent this year.
Really significant economic pain there.
But even more pain in Ukraine.
As you can see, the World Bank is expecting that Ukraine's GDP...
...will collapse by nearly 50 percent this year, Dana.